for a short amount of time because
they're afraid of of
of the sun rays so then they go back go
back but yes
you will still be able to encounter them
during the day
another interesting thing you asked
about is the rooftops and
it's interesting because it touches on
the another very important concept of
dying light too which is that
the rooftops are being used but by the
people that live in the city to rebuild
the civilization
so while you will be exploring actually
you will see a lot of
safe houses
farm fields and additional stuff like
that
on the rooftops so they need to be safe
so
there aren't that many biters virals or
other infected
on the rooftops during the day but of
course when the night comes it's a
completely different type of story
because the day is for humans but the
night is for the infected
okay but what about the guns yes
guns another question that came up very
often so this is something we have also
been telling you guys already so uh
there are no firearms in the world of
dying light too
why because it's a world while the
civilization is destroyed
it's gone so actually no one is able to
create
like professional firearms there will be
wrenched weapons
bows and something extra which free
which fit
more the modern type ages idea the
modern like ages concept
having said that there's actually one
option you can
choose to use something similar to a
firearm and this is a handmade shotgun
a very nice tool we have introduced for
you to create craft
with the stuff you have you you can find
during exploration
when you craft it when you create it you
can start using it using your left hand
so you can have a shotgun in your left
hand and a machete or a sword or a
hammer in your second one
and it really allows you to combine
those two tools in combat encounters a
very
powerful combination but the thing is
that the shotgun
because it's handmade it doesn't last
long so it can get
destroyed very easily so it's up to you
when you decide to use
that powerful piece of of weapon
[Music]
okay so uh is the grappling hook still
in the game
or as it was in the extended gameplay
trailer
if yes how does it work so of course it
is still in the game
and uh we have really put a lot of
effort into making
it a completely new tool
a tool that's better than the one that
you
got used to in that late one so i think
the most important thing for us was to
make the grafting hook us
real as natural as physical as possible
so it works differently now you will not
be able to fly through the whole map
in one minute as in the first game
as i said it's way way more physical and
way way more
realistic so if you need something to to
to help you imagine this is that
in the first game with the grappling
hook you could almost feel like a
spiderman in this game in the second
game you feel more like a tarzan
so uh swinging on ropes and and
and everything so of course you could
say oh i prefer to be a spiderman and a
tyson
good for you but wait till you see the
thing in action
it's really really really immersive and
it has a lot of uses not only in
traversal not only
parkour but also in combat so trust us
we know what you what we're doing and
you will enjoy the new grappling hook a
lot
[Music]
oh this one is very important and very
interesting
the question is will there be cars
vehicles
in the main game area so the answer is
you will be driving inside a vehicle in
one specific mission the one we have
shown to you
at the in our last demo we didn't want
to spend
more time on it because we feel all of
our other traversal methods are way way
more interesting so of course you have
parkour
and with our natural movement system and
the improvements we have made
in the second game you can really travel
through the city
with great ease overcoming any obstacles
doing those huge jumps so it's really
really very exciting
and on top of that we also add the
grappling hook the paraglider
and some additional stuff we'll be
talking about in the future
so we wanted to stick to that because
this is the dna of dying light this is
what makes our game
unique
[Music]
okay so this one is actually another
question that appeared very very
frequently so the question is
how many choices do you have that
actually changed the world
and the story so i don't want to give
you an exact number
but i want to explain to you how the
whole system works
so in dying light 2 you make choices you
make decisions on
three different levels so the first one
the as you can say the the upper one the
top one
is a number of main story choices
a few of them which really change how
the story flows and
what kind of ending you will get when
you finish
the whole experience then the second
level is
choices and decisions you make inside
side quests
or even main quests that mostly have
consequences that are contained
within those quests within those
missions
or quite often they also influence the
world an example of this is
in one of the quests you can for example
save an opera singer
if you do that if you make a correct
choice then she
appears in one of the hubs in one of the
safe zones in the game
and starts singing some people like it
some people don't some people will tell
you
it was a stupid thing to do but it's all
up to you and this is an example of one
of those
little details that you can actually
change in your world
and the third level is the so-called
city alignment system
and this is a system where based on your
choices one of the factions takes
control over specific
areas of the city so when they do that
of course they
install their forces they install a lot
of
different things that belong to that
faction and some of the things are the
things that you can use in gameplay
so for example if you play with the
peacekeepers they start
installing so-called combat helpers
combat traps that you can use while
fighting with band-aids or infected or
whatever
if you side with survivors and you give
parts of the city to survivors they'll
start installing
things like zip lines and trampolines
and other stuff that makes the traversal
easier so depending on your choices you
can also shape
the gameplay space the gameplay
environment and have a different
experience depending on what you do
the next one is how diverse are regions
in dying light to
will we see fields and planes suburbs or
any additional locations so as you know
the game takes place inside the city and
it's a huge city so as all of
the huge cities out there in the world
is actually quite diverse
you can say that there are two main
regions
in the city which is an area which is a
little bit close to old town
and another one which is more like a
downtown with
huge skyscrapers and all of that stuff
within those regions there are seven
zones where you can make decisions and
assign those zones to different factions
so for example if you side with
survivors you will start seeing things
like
fields or bakeries or
other small communities that are
building rebuilding themselves around
various city locations
and if you said with peacekeepers you
will start seeing more of our military
stuff like
outposts barricades things like that
so depending on your choices and how you
assign each of the zones
you can end up with a completely
different looking type of city
hey everyone we've been quiet for some
time
since like the rest of the world we had
some unforeseen hurdles to clear
but the wait is over
let's dive into the open world of dying
light ii
the last slice of dying light to
showcase the mission from the main
storyline
you get after those [ __ ] you saw how
your decisions influenced the narrative
and notably changed the environment
this time we want to give you a broader
look at the game and a sneak peek at
some of the things we'll be talking
about in upcoming months
in dying light 2 you become aiden
caldwell
an outsider trying to unravel a tangled
mystery from his past
its trail leads him to the city probably
the last bastion of mankind in the world
oh [ __ ]
at first you feel like this intense
brutal place will
tear you apart but then you meet the
night runners
veteran survivors who help people in
better days
by the way i'm a haircut you were a
night runner
you used to help people remember my
runners are gone
finished a myth
and although it's not entirely clear you
can trust them
you need allies in the dark
and these are the modern dark ages it's
been 15 years since the apocalypse and
the world has changed
the old civilization has fallen but a
new one
has been built on its ashes
people fight desperately for scarce
resources
the rules are broken and weakness is
punished
she's innocent three factions struggle
for position in the city
survivors pride themselves on being able
to adapt to any circumstances and cobble
together
safe zones almost everywhere
peacekeepers loyal soldiers who want to
impose their version of law and order
and trample all in their path
renegades ex-prisoners serving their
ruthless colonel
seeking to become sole rulers of the
city
where ease waltz
make him talk
use these factions to reach your goal
help or harm them to reshape the city to
your liking
just remember each faction contains
complex characters
nosy parker ain't you got some kind of
bad habit of yours
so will you follow cold calculation or
your heart
the bizarre needs good people help us
and you'll find a home here
some in the city offer no chance for an
alliance bandits
outlaws and common thugs live only to
plunder and kill
plunging the streets into chaos
yet nightfall scares all of them equally
darkness changes the rules of the world
as the light fails monsters crawl out of
hiding to prey on the poor souls caught
outside the safety of uv
rays hordes of infected pour into the
streets like decaying lava
the deadly spawn of 15 years of mutation
and evolution
your only escape exploit the city's
verticality and flee to the roofs
even there you are never safe from swift
and deadly virals
yet night brings opportunity as well
nests rife with infected during the day
now light empty
to explore them you must tread carefully
but those brave enough to face the
terrors of the night can loot a jackpot
[Music]
luckily you have all the tools you need
to survive
your extraordinary parkour skills allow
you to navigate even the most
treacherous terrain
on the roofs you can count on your
parkour acrobatics to save your life
but often you'll have to face your
enemies head on and then you have to be
smart
resourceful
and determined
[Music]
we've worked hard on the essence of our
combat making sure swinging
a big meaty weapon is fun satisfying
and well executed
but even the most brutal fights can be
tactical as well
you have multiple ways to hone your
skills toward the gameplay style that
suits you best
it's up to you if you focus mostly on
mobility and parkour
or aggressive blunt force combat or
a crafty approach where the tools you've
created get the job done
every ability you learn can be a game
changer and possibly
a new favorite move
things move fast and quick in dying
light too each moment matters
each move could mean triumph or defeat
choose your actions and friends
carefully everything you do in the city
can reshape the gameplay environment
change the course of the narrative and
decide the fate of the city's residents
but most importantly you decide your own
fate as well you're about to turn
make sure to stay human
[Music]
um
[Music]
hi everyone so the next question is
from the footage we have already seen
aiden seems much less confident and more
nervous than crain
will the game's plot focus on his growth
as a person
the same way the first game focused a
lot on crane and his changing motives
so the answer is yes absolutely this is
what great stories are about
right so aidan is a defined character
when
when the game starts and he has his own
motives and he has his own
like mood and characteristics
and all of those things things impact
how he behaves at the start of the game
but he's also a character that is
searching for identity
and he's also searching for a discovery
for a secret from his past
which of course i cannot spoil to you at
this point because i would like you to
discover this
in game and but the thing is that
as the game progresses the character arc
builds and you have impact over the
character arc and actually by your
decisions
you will be able to kind of change or
decide
what item you will have at the end of
the whole story at the end of the whole
experience
so depending on your choices either can
be a little bit more selfish or a little
bit
more focused on the collective and the
needs of others
and i think this is the most important
thing that you will decide
regarding the character
another question and this one is about
gre
so the question is will the gre make a
return
or at least be a player in what led up
to the events in dying light 2.
i understand that dl2 is set far in the
future from dl1 but i find it a bit
difficult to imagine how an
organization with enough money and power
to fly in drops
and antis in daily could disappear if
the virus
wasn't wiped out the gre is such an
enormous organization they left
very many traces in the map
so yes this organization was very
wealthy
very powerful so imagine what can you
find
when looking for those traces so
yes gre is making a return in dying
light 2 and it will play a very
important part
in the overall world building of the
game
so you will see plenty of bits and
pieces and collectibles and
notes and references to what happened to
gre
and uh basically how it connect
how it connects and what role it plays
in the events between
uh dying light one and dying lights too
another thing is that you will also
encounter
a lot of gre related stuff in the game
and actually there will be even open
world activities
built around you discovering and
exploring
abundant gre labs and quarantine areas
so if you are really interested in the
backstory of gre you will have a lot of
places where you will be able to learn
it
the next question is about romance so
the question is
i don't really play games with romans in
them but
in the first dying late game jade and
crane had
somewhat of a relationship romantic
relationship going on
so can we expect to see something along
the same lines for dying light too
so for sure you will experience a lot of
very strong
very complex relations between people
between the main character and the npcs
between the npcs themselves
and of course there will be quite a few
very strong female characters
but we don't have romance options like
in bioware
games for example because this was never
our goal
[Music]
okay so the next one is the heavy one
and we have been asked this
basically since we announced the game so
the question is
which ending of the following is
canonical
so it's still a little bit too early
to say it all to you guys but
let me just tell you that the events in
dying light 2 and the events that have
led up
to dying light 2 are very strongly
connected to what happened
in the first game so when you play dying
light 2
you will surely discover the answer to
this big question
the story of dying like 2 takes place
several years
after the story of dying light 1. kyle
crane was
such an important person in all the
events that happened in dying light one
so he must have left at least an impact
of what will happen in the english too
this one is actually very interesting so
please listen closely
will it be possible to recreate the
technology
and the government or perhaps people
will be doomed to live in the modern
dark ages for a long time
so the question is straight and simple
we don't want to give you an option to
rebuild
the government and technology and
community
as we know it today why because to be
honest we thought that would actually be
quite boring we know that stuff
there's no point in rebuilding this what
is more interesting to us is actually
present
our own vision of what the future could
be
after an apocalypse like this so yes you
will stay
in the modern dark ages we created but
as has been said quite a few times in
this
ama you will be able to shape the future
by your decisions
so you will be able to decide what kind
of buildings what kind of structures
what kind of community
will the place be after you finish the
game
[Music]
there goes another one and this is
another one that we have been asked
since the first e3 when we announced the
game
so the question is will some characters
from dl1 be
returning in this game too or and if so
then can you name a few or maybe it's
confidential
so dying light 2 takes place in a
completely different place
and quite a lot of years after the
events of the first one so for this
reason
you will not encounter any returning
characters from the first game
but of course there will be quite a lot
of references to
what happened in the first game and also
some of the characters so
please keep a close eye on what what you
will be able to find
and discover in the game
[Music]
julia could you tell us will there be
more open world events such as the eye
drops from the first game
yes there will be a lot more open world
events in dying light too
not only we will have the living world
with
encounters all over but also you will be
able to explore new locations
such as gre quarantine or dark places
oh this is very very important it's
about the factions in the game so the
question is
what can you say about the main factions
in dying light 2
how do these two groups affect the
entire city
so yes there are two main factions in
the dying light world and it's
up to you to decide which one of those
you want to side with
so the thing about them is that their
strategy to survival differs so first of
all there are the peacekeepers
and these are the strong military types
so they
they they focus mostly on combat they
want to kill all of the infecteds
that are out there so they build
powerful weapons they
build powerful traps and they
work kind of like this military regime
the other faction is survivors
and they want to adapt they just want to
survive so they adapt to the environment
building their communities
planting fields and also investing and
focusing
on traversal they don't fight that much
they just want to be able to travel
the city easily and escape and the
threats so if you side with them you
will be
starting more and more of their of their
traversal helpers and you will be able
to use that as well
of course aside from the peacekeepers
and the survivors
there are other groups in the city the
next important one is the renegades
and they are basically the bad guys so
you will face them and you will have to
make some decisions how you want to deal
with them
and then there are also smaller groups
which are used mostly in side quests or
as like additional background characters
for the main quests
colorful people colorful groups with
their own
ideas agendas that you will be able to
discover while you'll be playing dying
light
too
there goes another question and it says
will i be able to side with no factions
and be an
enemy to all so you have to understand
that our world is extremely brutal
extremely primal and it's full of
threats and conflicts so if you have no
allies
you basically die very quickly and we
don't want you to die very quickly and
we also want you
to make a decision we also want you to
make a statement
so a lone wolf option is not available
you will have to decide if you want to
play with those guys or the other ones
[Music]
hi everyone my name is timon smachtawa
and i'm the lead game designer
of dying light too welcome to our
ama
[Music]
first of all i would like to thank all
of you for all of the
questions you have sent us it was more
than 9
000 questions so it's a lot we have
chosen
the one that were appearing most
frequently
[Music]
so first the number one question how big
is the map of dying light 2
so this is something we have said before
it's about double the size of all of the
maps from
dying light 1 combined if you have
played the first game i think it will be
easy for you to imagine how big
the map will be you will you just take
the slums you take the old town
you combine them and you double the
number and that's roughly the size of
the game space in dying light too
if you wanna know the number it's more
than six square kilometers big
almost seven square kilometers but
that's a simple answer
which doesn't take into account the
verticality of the world
so just imagine there are hundreds of
buildings and each one of them has at
least a couple of floors
there are even skyscrapers there are
roofs bridges
all of that stuff so you can imagine how
big the actual
space you'll be playing in is
oh that's a good one what is that zombie
with branches on its back
volatiles already gave me mini heart
attacks i'm worried i will lose my life
now
i'm worried as well because the
volatiles in dying light too are even
more scary
so the fingers crossed for you and
answering a question
the guy with the branches he's actually
a new
type of infected in our game and uh i
don't want to spoil too much
because we are preparing a huge drop of
information about
our infected that's coming but what i
can tell you right now is that he is
definitely not
a nice guy and he will also give you
quite a lot of those mini heart attacks
[Music]
the interesting thing about this guy is
that you can actually
make him happen make him appear in your
game
so the fact that he appears in your
world is
just one of the consequences that you
can have when you
make specific decisions so if he really
is that scary for you
just try to make good decisions and
maybe he will not
haunt your dreams
if there's just going to be zombies at
night or will we see some wandering
around on rooftops
that's a very good question because it
touches on the most important rule
of the world of dying light 2 which is
the days for humans
but the night and the night is for the
infected what that means is that during
the day
they infected hide inside buildings
inside
dark places where they can avoid sun
rays or uvulates
so yes there are less of them on the
streets during the day
but it doesn't mean you won't encounter
them there are still some
some some of them are weakened some of
them are slower but they still
pose a threat another threat that you
have to face during the day is of course
bandaids and other humans but that's
a different type of story another story
one more thing that you can do is you
can actually draw the infected from the
hiding places for example if you make a
lot of noise so then they run
away run from run from their hiding
places
and they try to attack you they try to
fight with you or
some other npcs some other humans around
of course it lasts only for a short
amount of time because they're afraid of
of of the sun rays so then they go back
go back but
yes you will still be able to encounter
them during the day
another interesting thing you asked
about is the rooftops and it's
interesting because it touches on the
another very important concept of dying
light too which is that
the rooftops are being used but by the
people that live in the city to rebuild
the civilization
so while you will be exploring actually
you will see a lot of
safe houses
farm fields and additional stuff like
that
on the rooftops so they need to be safe
so
there aren't that many biters virals or
other infected
on the rooftops during the day but of
course when the night comes it's a
completely different type of story
because the day is for humans but the
night is for the infected
okay but what about the guns yes
guns another question that came up very
often so this is something we have also
been telling you guys you guys already
so uh
there are no firearms in the world of
dying light too
why because it's a world while the
civilization is destroyed
it's gone so actually no one is able to
create
like professional firearms there will be
ranged weapons
bows and something extra which which fit
more
the modern type ages idea the modern-day
aegis concept
having said that there's actually one
option you can
choose to use something similar to a
firearm and this is a handmade shotgun
a very nice tool we have introduced for
you to create craft with the stuff you
have found you you can find during
exploration
when you craft it when you create it you
can start using it using your left hand
so you can have a shotgun in your left
hand and a machete or a sword or a
hammer in your second one
and it really allows you to combine
those two tools in combat encounters a
very
powerful combination but the thing is
that the shotgun because it's handmade
it doesn't last long so
it can get destroyed very easily so it's
up to you when you decide to use
that powerful piece of weapon
[Music]
okay so uh is the grappling hook still
in the game
or as it was in the extended gameplay
trailer
if yes how does it work so of course it
is still in the game
and we have really put a lot of effort
into making
it a completely new tool
a tool that's better than the one that
you
got used to in dire glade one so i think
the most important thing for us
was to make the grappling hook as real
as natural
as physical as possible so um it works
differently now
you will not be able to fly to the whole
map in one minute
as in the first game uh as i said it's
way way more
physical and way way more realistic so
if you need something to to to help you
imagine this is that
in the first game with the grappling
hook you could almost feel like a
spiderman in this game in the second
game you feel more like a tarzan
so swinging on ropes and and
and everything so of course you could
say oh i prefer to be a spiderman and a
tyson
good for you but wait till you see the
thing in action
it's really really really immersive and
it has a lot of uses not only in
traversal not only parkour
but also in combat so trust us we know
what you what we're doing and
you will enjoy the new grappling hook a
lot
[Music]
oh this one is very important and very
interesting
the question is will there be cars
vehicles
in the main game area so the answer is
you will be driving inside a vehicle in
one specific mission the one we have
shown to you
at in our last demo we didn't want to
spend
more time on it because we feel all of
our other traversal methods are way way
more interesting so of course you have
parkour
and with our natural movement system and
the improvements we have made
in the second game you can really travel
through the city
with great ease overcoming any obstacles
doing those huge jumps so it's really
really very exciting
and on top of that we also add the
grafting hook the paraglider
and some additional stuff we'll be
talking about in the future
so we wanted to stick to that because
this is the dna of dying light this is
what makes
our game unique
[Music]
okay so this one is actually another
question that appeared very very
frequently so the question is
how many choices do you have that
actually changed the world and the story
so i don't want to give you an exact
number but i want to explain to you
how the whole system works so in dying
light 2 you make
choices you make decisions on three
different levels
so the first one the as you can see the
the upper one the top one
is a number of main story choices
a few of them which really change how
the story flows and
what kind of ending you will get when
you finish
the whole experience then the second
level is
choices and decisions you make inside
side quests
or even main quests that mostly have
consequences that are contained
within those quests within those
missions
or quite often they also influence the
world an example of this is
in one of the quests you can for example
save an opera singer
if you do that if you make a correct
choice then she
appears in one of the hubs in one of the
safe zones in the game
and starts singing some people like it
some people don't some people will tell
you
it was a stupid thing to do but it's all
up to you and this is an example of one
of those
little details that you can actually
change in your world
and the third level is the so-called
city alignment system
and this is a system where based on your
choices one of the factions
takes control over specific areas of the
city
so when they do that of course they
install their forces they install
a lot of different things that belong to
that faction and some of the things are
the things that you can use in gameplay
so for example if you play with the
peacekeepers they start
installing so-called combat helpers
combat traps that you can use while
fighting with band-aids or infected or
whatever
if you side with survivors and you give
parts of the city to survivors
they'll start installing things like zip
lines and
trampolines and other stuff that makes
the traversal easier
so depending on your choices you can
also shape the gameplay space the
gameplay
environment and have a different
experience
depending on what you do
[Music]
the next one is how diverse are regions
in dying light too
will we see fields and planes suburbs or
any additional locations so as you know
the game takes place inside the city and
it's a huge city so as all of
the huge cities out there in the world
is actually quite diverse
you can say that there are two main
regions
in the city which is an area which is a
little bit close to
old town and another one which is more
like a downtown with
huge skyscrapers and all of that stuff
within those regions there are seven
zones where you can make decisions and
assign those zones to different factions
so for example if you side with
survivors you will start seeing
things like fields or bakeries or
other small communities that are
building rebuilding themselves around
various city locations
and if you said with peacekeepers you
will start seeing more of our military
stuff like
outposts barricades things like that
so depending on your choices and how you
assign
each of the zones you can end up with a
completely different looking
type of city
[Music]
hey everyone we've been quiet for some
time
since like the rest of the world we had
some unforeseen hurdles to clear
but the wait is over
let's dive into the open world of dying
light too
the last slice of dying light 2
showcased emissions from the main
storyline
you get after those [ __ ]
saw how your decisions influenced the
narrative and notably changed the
environment
this time we want to give you a broader
look at the game and a sneak peek at
some of the things we'll be talking
about in upcoming months
in dying light 2 you become aiden
caldwell an outsider trying to unravel a
tangled mystery from his past
its trail leads him to the city probably
the last bastion of mankind in the world
first you feel like this intense brutal
place will
tear you apart but then you meet the
night runners
veteran survivors who help people in
better days
by the way i'm a hay gun you were a
night runner
you used to help people remember my
runners are gone
finished a myth
and although it's not entirely clear you
can trust them
you need allies in the dark
and these are the modern dark ages it's
been 15 years since the apocalypse and
the world has changed
the old civilization has fallen but a
new one
has been built on its ashes
[Music]
people fight desperately for scarce
resources
rules are broken and weakness is
punished
she's innocent three factions struggle
for position in the city
survivors pride themselves on being able
to adapt to any circumstances
and cobble together safe zones almost
everywhere
peacekeepers loyal soldiers who want to
impose their version of law and order
and trample all
in their path renegades ex-prisoners
serving their ruthless colonel seeking
to become
sole rulers of the city where
ease walls making
use these factions to reach your goal
help or harm them to reshape the city to
your liking
just remember each faction contains
complex characters
nosey parker ain't ya got some kind of
bad habit of yours
so will you follow cold calculation
or your heart the bizarre needs good
people
help us and you'll find a home here some
in the city offer no
chance for an alliance bandits outlaws
and common thugs live
only to plunder and kill plunging the
streets into chaos
yet nightfall scares all of them equally
darkness changes the rules of the world
as the light fails the monsters crawl
out of hiding to prey on the poor souls
caught outside the safety of
uv rays hordes of infected pour into the
streets like decaying lava
the deadly spawn of 15 years of mutation
and evolution your only escape
exploit the city's verticality and flee
to the roofs
even there you are never safe from swift
and deadly virals
yet night brings opportunity as well
nests rife with infected during the day
now light empty
to explore them you must tread carefully
but those brave enough to face the
terrors of the night can
loot a jackpot
luckily you have all the tools you need
to survive
your extraordinary parkour skills allow
you to navigate even the most
treacherous
[Music]
on the terrain you can count on your
parkour acrobatics to save your life
but often you'll have to face your
enemies head on and then you have to be
smart
resourceful
and determined
[Music]
we've worked hard on the essence of our
combat making sure swinging a big
moody weapon is fun satisfying and well
executed
but even the most brutal fights can be
tactical as well
you have multiple ways to hone your
skills toward the gameplay style that
suits you best
it's up to you if you focus mostly on
mobility and parkour
or aggressive blunt force combat or
a crafty approach where the tools you've
created get the job done
every ability you learn can be a game
changer and possibly a new favorite move
things move fast and quick in dying
light too each moment matters
each move could mean triumph or defeat
choose your actions and friends
carefully everything you do in the city
can reshape the gameplay environment
change the course of the narrative and
decide the fate of the city's residents
but most importantly you decide you're
on fate as well you're about to turn
make sure to stay
[Music]
close your human
[Music]
[Music]
hi everyone so the next question is
from the footage we have already seen
aiden seems much less confident
and more nervous than crain will the
game's plot focus on his growth as a
person
the same way the first game focused a
lot on crane and his changing motives
so the answer is yes absolutely this is
what great stories
are about right so iden is a defined
character when
when the game starts and he has his own
motives and he has his own
like mood and characteristics
and all of those things things impact
how he behaves
at the start of the game but he's also a
character that
is searching for identity and is also
searching for a
discovery for a secret from his past
which of course i cannot spoil to you at
this point because i would like you to
discover this
in-game and but the thing is that
as the game progresses the character arc
builds and you have impact over the
character arc
and actually by your decisions you will
be able to
kind of change or decide what
item you will have at the end of the
whole story at the end of the whole
experience
so depending on your choices i then can
be a little bit more selfish
or a little bit more focused on the
collective and the needs of others
and i think this is the most important
thing that you will decide
regarding the character
[Music]
another question and this one is about
gre
so the question is will the gre make a
return
or at least be a player in what led up
to the events in dying light 2.
i understand that dl2 is set far in the
future from dl1 but i find it a bit
difficult to imagine how an
organization with enough money and power
to fly in drops
and antis in daily could disappear if
the virus
wasn't wiped out the gre is such an
enormous organization
they left
[Music]
recon be careful
[Music]
it's clear
hello and welcome to the second episode
of dying to know
if you missed the first episode you can
still catch it on youtube where you'll
learn more about the game
about the release date and catch the
latest gameplay trailer
today we're going to be talking about
the infected in dying light 2
with some of the people who helped
create them but right now i'm sure
you're wondering where
is jonah well jonah is hard at work
right now in la recording some of the
voices for
dying light too so we'll forgive him for
his absence but he has left a message
for you
hey guys uh good news i'm in la and
we're finishing up voice recordings for
aiden in dying light 2
and this particular quest we're working
on right now showcases a lot of the
disgusting horrific freaks of nature
that you're going to fight in the game
itself
the better news is that the episode
today of dying to know
focuses almost entirely on those
monsters and leia is going to
tell you all about them and it's going
to be fantastic the bad news is
i'm not going to be there in the studio
at least this time i'm going to be in
this studio recording lines
for a while but leia's going to take
good care of you
we're we're gonna make sure that you get
everything you need to know and i i
think i i think i gotta go back to work
um
leah the stage is yours good night good
luck and remember to stay human
thanks jonah well we might not be in
sunny la right now but we do have
something just as exciting to talk about
the monsters we're going to be looking
at how they're created we're going to be
venturing into the night in a new
gameplay trailer we're going to be
seeing what's new on techland gg
and more
but first let's take a moment to thank
our amazing community
you we love seeing you react to our
content and your comments help motivate
the entire team
so thank you over 750
000 of you tuned in to the first dying
to know live stream
over 10 million of you have watched the
first gameplay reveal trailer
and over 17 million comments have been
left across our social media channels
on all platforms it's amazing thank you
there is literally nobody who would
rather explore the darkness alongside
than you
our first guest today is timon smith
tower the lead game designer for
dying light to stay human
hello timon hi hello hello welcome to
the show um
so we're talking about monsters today
and where the monsters start they start
in the imagination of the game designers
like yourself and the others so
what can you tell us about them so first
of all i think it's important to say
that our monsters used to be sick and
suffering people who just didn't manage
to find uv light
or any other cure in time the virus
causes them
a lot of pain and it makes them suffer
and they are not driven by hatred
but by instinct their new nature right
okay so what does that process look like
for returning from a human to a monster
so at first you get symptoms similar to
fever
and at this stage the process can still
be slowed down or even paused
but if you spend too much time in
darkness the sickness progresses
and your symptoms become more severe and
eventually
you will turn into a volatile a quick
agile aggressive
bloodthirsty monster right and if it
gets to that point is there anything you
can do
is it reversible well unfortunately once
you have turned there's no way to revert
and now the uv light becomes your enemy
so if you spend too much time in the sun
you will degrade into a slow-moving and
shambling biter
so with that sun sensitivity then so
it's fair to say you're kind of safe
outside in the daylight apart from the
biters uh well yes and no
of course you will see less monsters on
the streets than during the night
but you will still encounter some as the
sun weakens them they try to find a
place to hide
usually inside buildings but don't go
into those nests
a day as they are swarming with the
infected right okay
so i mean you know if i fancy going in
during the day for some reason is there
any chance and no no absolutely no
so because if you do it during the day
it's a certain death
right but you can explore those places
at night okay and because of that we
have greatly improved our stealth
mechanics
so now you can go to the entire dark
zone completely unnoticed
that is as long as you stay quiet and
don't misstep
right okay which is like my kryptonite
because i will absolutely kick a bucket
back no absolutely don't do that never
do that
never kick no never kick the bucket no
dying
and not only that but you can encounter
other special infected as well
so can you tell us a little bit about
those absolutely so
they were created by chemicals that made
the infection progress too fast
causing mutations so sometimes when you
stay quiet sneak behind them
and observe them you will see that they
seem to be uncomfortable
in their new body as if they didn't have
time to get used to them
wow okay and they're all like quite
unique and different as well aren't they
well yes everyone is unique and for
example the revenant
who is my personal favorite he has those
things coming from his back almost like
wings
he's very scary very dangerous but also
smart and intelligent
and to capture this part of his nature
we have kept his appearance more human
i think smart and intelligent are two of
my least favorite things when
encountering an enemy that sounds that
scary
wow well um thank you so much for
joining us today thank you for having me
and now why don't we take a sneak peek
at some of those monsters in action
in this brand new gameplay video
so you have an army here
the peacekeepers seriously riling up the
bazaar folks
i'll proceed with caution are we going
you uh wanted to show me something sure
follow
you won't get far me a biomarker
without it you don't know when you turn
uh
i'm waiting by the lobby
sleeping beauties yeah we have to walk
past them
if you crouch and move slowly they
shouldn't notice you
get too close and you're done
uh
where is that chemicals nasty [ __ ] house
the whole hospital with it
along with the patients and stuff
[Music]
he wanted to stop the infection at that
cost
[Music]
[Music]
so
we got company
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
yeah that's great
sorry about this what i'm sorry about
what
about that on behalf of all its [ __ ]
bandits and idiots
i christen you a citizen of vilidor
you're about to turn get into the night
[Music]
fast
um
[Applause]
that was wild and if you want to see
how the creatures we've just seen were
created kashabek the lead character
concept artist
and dominic vashenko the lead 3d
character artist
are here to tell us more
hello welcome to the show hello hello so
my first question for you today is how
did you come up with all of the like
forms and shapes for the monsters in the
game so first we had to create a general
idea of how virus could
evolve visually okay we used elements
from various skin diseases
like hardness tissue working as organic
armor
blisters filled with yellow paths as
weak points
and some burnt skin scars to create
interesting texture on the skin
yeah yeah for example we have the
morissero and his blisters they shine at
night
and that's because we wanted our
monsters to be like really visible and
recognizable in the darkness yeah for
sure and um
you can must have had this idea from the
start then that you wanted the
demolisher to be the bigger and tougher
of the monsters right yeah we knew that
he would throw heavy objects
or chart and our goal was to make a
silhouette really monumental
and aggressive just to like to show that
strength okay so the demolish is
probably one of the bigger monsters in
the game um have you got an example of
like the smaller monsters maybe yes of
course
for example we have banshee she's
insanely fast and agile because of that
she needs to be of course smaller than
the demolisher and she doesn't have like
the hardened tissue that we saw on him
but i wouldn't mess with her yeah we
really wanted her femininity to show so
she's wearing a dress that was pretty
ragged now
and also she's wearing jewelry that's
fused into her body while she was
turning
and her hands grow larger than the rest
of her body
almost same like in demolitions but here
the disproportion is much bigger
wow yeah and i feel like there's a story
behind that with like the jaw refuses
the body that's so
intense but why are her hands so big
basically there are her weapons so yeah
because she strikes
from above her fingers grow longer
and also sharper to cut not to hit
because due to her lower strength yeah
she's going for the kill
exactly um so does that mean we can be
expecting banshee to jump
from the roof down on us yes she's so
fast and i'd like that she might
surprise the player like by striking the
middle
so yeah something that no other like
monster can do no
okay yeah i can't see the demolisher
doing that
um thank you so much for joining us
today and uh sharing more about the
process of design thank you
thank you
well if you like stories we've got a bit
of a treat for you
when it gets dark at night and the
monsters leave their lairs
and roam at the city streets the
residents of the city like to gather in
their safe spots
under the uv lamps for protection and
wait out until the dawn
and when they're doing that they like to
kill time by telling stories themselves
about banshee for example you're
wondering why she's wearing that
beautiful necklace and ball gown
well now you can find out
oh
[Music]
techland have partnered with dynamite to
create a comic series and this
is just a teaser of what to expect you
can get a physical copy yourself in
store
soon but if you head to techlandg.com
you can also get a digital version for
free
and also on teclan gg there is plenty
more content
you can find a brand new starter pack
more information about the monsters
you can get a six piece outfit coming
very very soon
more information about the game entirely
the dying to know shows
basically everything so why don't you
check it out for yourself at
techlandgg.com
i feel like i know quite a lot about
monsters now but if there's one thing
that intrigues me it's how do you make
something so
inhuman and terrifying come to life in
game
luckily we have the one person who can
answer that question here with us today
it's dying light 2's animation director
david lubrica
and he's here to tell us more
welcome w hello welcome hello so you
work with the animation team in taking
all that concept art and bringing it to
life and having like an actual living
breathing monster in the game so where
do you even start with that
so the process starts with creating a
prototype and then designing
choreography based on this
then we take it to the mock-up shoot and
that's where we
have our actors interpret the movements
and we actually learn from them
also that gives us some extra ideas but
the real magic happens
when we take all the things we captured
and start putting in into the engine
and into the games language okay can you
give us an example of that in game
sure like volatile for example so he
sniffs around he searches for his prey
he has those cut like jumps
but many of those movements are actually
characteristics of
the creatures we know from animal
documentaries and he combines them with
some new ones and unique ones and that's
what makes him who he actually is
oh okay okay so i'm going to be like in
game i'm going to be searching him out
and
trying to see all these little details
you've made which is probably not the
best idea because i think that will get
me killed
right yeah with him it's not the best
idea uh but we have other infecteds
and all of them actually have very very
distinctive and interesting behaviors
okay so you've given them all like
unique personalities in-game
sure so let's take a look at hauler for
example
he doesn't fight he's more of an alarm
like this
light tower you know searching for prey
he screams to call other infected when
he spots human
but also he sometimes rises on his
tiptoes
to see better to see his surroundings
but that also makes him
look like this very scared you know
panic child
why is he so scared well it's because
there are some traces of his humanity in
him
he he really wants to scream but the
virus has attacked his
lungs and and vocal cords and that would
just hurt him too much
he's helpless but they all just lose
this fight with their instincts done at
some point
totally um actually they rather evoke
pity
they you can see that they can notice
the deformations
the virus has done to their bodies they
can touch them
they can experience something like
seizures
and you can see that all this aggression
all this
rage is repressed in them and
you know something might trigger it and
that's usually an opponent
and you can see that all this energy is
released
and uh transferred on the opponent on
the player for example us i can't wait
to see that in game
um but i want to talk about banshee
because we mentioned her earlier
we've seen how she looks but like how is
she animated
she's uh she's curious one she uh she
has those really long deformed fingers
uh and she uses them to fight with kind
of like a byproduct and we had to
imagine how she would feel about them
and we thought they must really bother
her right
yeah she can get really clumsy with them
she
falls on them in this very uncontrolled
way
as if she was forgetting she had them so
it's a bit of a curse
and an asset for them she's like
inflicted totally she's
really conflicted you can actually see
her sometimes actively hunting you
and then at some point if she gets too
close to you during combat she'll
just suddenly jump back and cower as if
she was trying to resist the virus
but ultimately she would just give in to
its power
wow this has been fascinating thank you
so much david thanks for having me
if you've ever wondered which of the
infected in the world of dying light you
might be then i've got good news
you can check out a quiz at dying light
game dot com forward slash witch monster
and find out whether you'd be i don't
know a violent
volatile a tough demolisher or maybe
a human take the test and share it with
your friends because
you know you need allies out here in the
darkness even
if you're an infected or maybe
especially if you're
infected and if you can't wait until
december the 7th to find out more about
the world of dying light why not check
out what's been added to dying light 1.
within the last month over half a
million new players have entered the
world of dying light
and we've had the highest number of
active players across
all platforms since launch which is
amazing
you are amazing thank you so much for
your support
and your interest in the world of dying
light more and more fun content is on
the way to dying light
one also like the savvy gamer dlc or the
fourth of july event
and if you head to teclan gg you could
get your hands on this
in-game weapon the wasp so you know why
not check out teclon gg as if you needed
more reason too
more and more fun content is added to
the game regularly so keep
checking it out with more coming soon
all right well since dying to know is
about the world of dying light
too there's still something else we need
to hear about
if you pardon the pun because we're
going to be talking about the sound
design of dying light 2.
if you've ever wondered about where the
roaring the growling the screaming that
covers the streets of the city at night
comes from then you're in the right
place because we're going to be talking
to one of the lead sound designers
to tell you more
senior sound designer tomx shedak is
here with us today hello hi
nice to meet you too hello um so first
question
do the monsters have their own language
they technically are not heard
creatures so they didn't develop sounds
to communicate with each other although
there are some exceptions for example
howler when attacked
he would say scream to alert other other
infected and then you can get yourself
into
really big troubles very very very soon
let's talk about the process of actually
creating those sounds though
and so you have to imagine what a
volatile might sound like from scratch
and
where do you even start with that well
you know the virus the
deformed infecteds in very different
ways and you have to reflect it in their
in their voices so for example the
acid spitting monster you know has to
have sound with some kind of
acidic characteristics some some watery
hissing uh stuff in it and there is the
banshee a
woman monster and her voice is
high-pitched and
vibrating and really really scary so you
work alongside your twin brother wojtek
and he
also records a lot of the sounds that
you use to create these monsters and we
actually have a video of that process so
we can have a closer look at what that
[Music]
entails
ah
yeah so now you can see how how it works
we always start with the human throat
because all of the infected where humans
wants
and then the creative part is coming and
a lot of sound design magic is happening
also we have to
cover a lot of emotions in in the
infected voices
because you have to know i mean the
player has to know if the
infected is is in pain or is super
aggressive or is maybe dying
we have to pass this message through the
voice and the message has to be very
very
very clear so basic monster like a biter
has 700
voice assets so the scale is it's
enormous
yeah that's a lot to try and communicate
and it just sounds
um so that's the monsters but what about
the entire city
our city is dying so we had to find
these abandoned places where there is no
sound of the civilization we visited
abandoned factories
we visited post-military bunkers we went
to the forest at minus 15 degrees
because it sounds completely different
than
in the summer and we climb up the
mountains it was a lot of
interesting places we wouldn't visit
without the dying light too and you know
at night with the good headphones
you can definitely enjoy it i cannot
wait to hear it it sounds like you've
got a
fascinating job i agree thank you so
much for coming in today thank you for
having me
and you could check out the hard work of
the shiddag brothers and their teams
when dying light 2 releases
on december the 7th
you can become a part of that amazing
universe remember the ugc contest
it's already started so just show us
your art to be in with a chance of
winning a copy
of the already sold out collector's
edition and join the world of dying
light
2. just look at all the amazing things
people have already created
dying light 2 releases later this year
on december the 7th and you can
pre-order it right now
but if you want to dive into the
universe immediately then why don't you
check out teclan gg for more news
updates and to grab your free copy of
the banshee comic
all right i think we know everything
about monsters now
except for one thing how to defeat them
so stay tuned for the next episode
we'll be looking at different combat
styles weapon crafting
and the iconic dying light 2 parkour
which was designed in cooperation with
this man
[Music]
yeah you'll do better on your own trust
me
thanks for watching episode 2 of dying
to know and remember
the virus isn't the only thing that
makes a monster
so stay human
[Music]
so
[Music]
you